[Musique]
bonjour nous sommes avec manuel manuel
est un jeune qui de dynamique tueur des
gee-gees éric infante bonjour je suis
avec manuel manuel est un jeu kid key
lamic dynamique
oui c'est ça manuel on va te poser la
première question traditionnelle est ce
que tu aimes à cette chose beaucoup de
choses oui ou énormément de choses dans
les normes et votre choix là tu peux le
dire
j'aime énormément de choses dans ma vie
dans la vie voilà de plus en plus rare
de rencontrer des jeunes comme toi qui
aime beaucoup de choses dans la vie
qu'est ce que tu aimes dans la vie
beaucoup de choses à wayne mais je
pouvais lire tu aimes des choses
beaucoup de choses plein de choses à
cette chose est-elle vraiment beaucoup
de choses où il ne peut a assez
+ 2 reims beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
choses ou bompas taux bas pas mal de
choses j'aime bien tu aimes bien de pas
mal de choses sont là c'est sa m1
s'étaient massés fatema c'est beaucoup
de choses
voilà exactement est-ce que tu peut
synthétiser ce que tu peux nous dire et
le redire pour les auditeurs je ne sais
pas la radio radio carottes
manuel at war synthétise que tu as à
dire
je m'appelle manuel j'aime pas mal de
choses non à ces beaucoup passer
beaucoup de choses sauf les walkman
parce que ça fait mal aux oreilles très
bien la chose explique c'est un problème
d'adoption il faut un reportage sur moi
j'ai 33 ans j'ai fait une demande
d'adoption la dass à 23 ans qu'on
pouvoir avoir un enfant adoptif et quand
il est arrivé il ya deux mois ma femme
est partie parce que ses questions
étaient très complexe c'est à dire que
la procédure était non qu'elle a mis dix
ans aujourd'hui l'enfant est arrivé chez
moi et celui qu'il a 10 ans de plus que
moi
régis il a 43 ans j'en ai 33 pas son
temps avec ses copains jouent au baby
foot je suis son père
la boîte plus âgées que moi c'est mon
fils j'en ai la responsabilité qu'est ce
que vous pouvez dire à cet enfant en
tant que femme qui pourrait lui
expliquer qu'il pourrait le convaincre
de poursuivre ses études de les
reprendre a des preuves
j'avais suivi ils mettent un peu tourner
la tête les mains hors de tes poches
c'est très important
on a besoin de travailler de ce manque
c'est très très important
écoutons mais bon il aussi à beaucoup de
marques et déjà de vous avoir adopté
déjà en premier lieu depuis
mais c'est très très important parce
qu'après je ne regretterai toute la nuit
et moi je suis plutôt rajevac a tous
pensé que vient dans l'avenir alors tu
répond aujourd'hui à tout fait pour
autant de sorties
et donc c'est très très important débat
et lui demander de les regarder
étrangères station mais c'est vrai il
faut vraiment temps de votre carcela
beaucoup moins non mais c'est déjà
travaillé dans la tête je laisse déjà
tant moi je suis pas barbu je me rassure
du matin est ce que vous pensez pas que
c'est assez gentil pour écouter j'ai
pour moi la jeunesse j'aime bien les
jeunes ils font ce qu'ils veulent et
c'est vrai c'est normal un peu pas non
plus et il faut qu'ils fassent du sport
ils jouent au baby foot il faut aussi
bon je ne suis pas content qu'ils se
désaltère canton soit mais la bière la
bière dans des pays moins de mon
élection plaît explique amy ce que ça
veut dire une attitude responsable
mais ce prix il expliqué ce que s'agira
claudel et même en est pas là voilà vous
pouvez leur dire cette écoute écoute
dégage à votre père était défensif yann
syz dame sait ce que c'est une dame
ouais comme on dirait pas non écoute la
remercie menacée on est aussi la dame
est ce que tu as compris la leçon
oui oui oui ma base
je vais pas faire de souci parce que
c'est de là qu'ils travaillent les
garçons c'est là
car ce film
et 15 à 17 ans
il vole l'argent aux riches mise
vous allez gérer vraiment
pas d'armes
ça
sinon si nous voyons clavier qui était
en train de voler quelque chose suivante
eps saison des interventions
d'intervention française de coca cola
[Applaudissements]
dans son sein qui dans le portefeuille
l'accusé
c'est que ma musique
par après
vous l'aimez des intrigants
des docks des habitués à saint-tricat ça
juste pour vous montrer
rien il l'a fait pour moi je parlais est
et on travaille là à neuilly j'espère
que vous n'avez pas m'en passer pour
quelque chose
je connais que les croquis très bon est
ce que c'est ça où je passais pas ça
évidemment mais est ce que c'est
possible juste quand vous serez installé
leur on pourra négocié ensemble sur
cette implantation d'un cirque on puisse
rester ici tranquillement à travailler
nous ne donnerons pas de permis non à
quelqu'un pour les 8es de notre groupe
est de protéger et de protéger les gens
et les choses
donc si vous voyez en train d'opérer par
exemple penser que c'est possible de
donner d'aussi
quelque chose devait pas ce que je vais
vous dire pourquoi je suis venu négocier
c'est que si vous empêchez les gars ont
travaillé et se retrouvent au chômage
et à ce moment là ils sont
incontrôlables moi j'ai plus responsable
[Musique]
bien sûr nous avons
beaucoup de petits croquis nous avons
attrapé vous le fils pompier et tout ça
à new york et à londres
nous avons l'obligation de rester là
pendant la procession
là d'accord et si la victime veut de
savate de voleurs et envoyée
policiers dans ce succès
[Musique]
vous insistez de fait si vous insistez
du fait des crimes devant moi se refuse
à ce moment pour voir référence passion
ils ont placé des charges contre contre
bourg
un petit nerveux
si nos habitudes
bonne journée serait ce comme opposées
déposez des charges encore merci a
bientot jeu s'appelle est un ancien
boucher
au revoir
[Musique]
je m'appelle je me roule hâte que vous
mettez vous ai vu à la télé non soignée
résine et tout ça corresponde résout
rien ajouté mme lydia pour une minute je
vous explique mon problème je suis des
repêchages dessous voyant dans la région
parisienne puisque j'étais voyant way et
la parapsychologie tout ça bon le
problème que j'ai c'est que je dois
faire une sur des visions l'ardhis
prochain france car la barge parce que
nécessaire
je me demande d'autres
devant que cette présentation pour que
j'ai participé à cette édition qui verra
soir voyance malheureusement en ce
moment chez amp est fort maison et
jacques doit fermer tout bon donc je
vais avoir du mal à être sélectionné
parmi les autres gagnants est-ce que
vous pouvez m'aider quoi pour mais
toujours là je n'ai plus qu'une minute
si c'est possible justement vous y
croyez vous la parasitologie plus ou
moins par plutôt qu'ils soient jamais
participé à participer demain jamais
vraiment branché alors dans ce film
présenté en ce sens
donc bien que j'ai rencontrés dans la
route comme ça et puis avec qui je fais
tout moi donc voilà je suis jeune et
roulottes et je vous présente les cadres
sont rencontrés dans la rue
faire deux tours m
alors on fait un exercice qui est très
simple vous avez posé vos mains comme ça
sur moi j'emmène ma et votre longue
étape et j'ai bien fermé les yeux donc
vous fermez bien les yeux vous
concentrer je vais maintenant faire un
effort à quoi je me demandais vraiment
de bien vouloir vous présenterais je
vais devenir votre numéro de sécurité
sociale alors attention
dumas brève satan
575 euros
cent dix heures
encore jésus
alors je vais maintenant deviner votre
nuit l'antiquité social 1,55
11 75 79 36
110 0,66 et examens oui
ah oui c'est des phrases exact il ya
patrick je demande donc d'ouvrir les
yeux je vous remercie pour cette
première expérience
alors donc c'est étonnant donc ça
fatigue un peu
on va faire cette invitation vous mettre
en face de moi vous inquiétez pas un
problème
alors le premier exercice de lévitation
consiste à éviter donc vous venait vers
moi et moi je voulais vite
patrick je vais vous demander de bien
vouloir lever le bras droit et puis
quand je vous dirais un vrai break
droite tous les deux vous devez le brave
aussi d'accord et vous ne les remet à
dos 1 1 2 ont tous fermé les yeux 3 4 et
là je vous l éviter
pour ce faire
et ça fait un peu bizarre mais le
français vous avez vu
[Musique]
je crois que vous avez vu une petite
lumière blanche au fond quand vous avez
fini de marcher c'est ça oui j'ai
l'impression que j'ai vu une petite
lumière via une petite lumière blanche
vous et moi je bafouille un petit peu
seul
oui peut-être bien et j'avais
l'impression d'être attiré par cette
lumière et on aurait dit une forme une
forme bizarre comme l'infini peut-être
une forme de dieu ou je ne sais pas
enfin cette impression d'être attiré
comme un aimant à quelle heure
comment 1 quelle heure à telle heure
on va
à chaleur bas
16 heures 16h01
15h55 donc à présent 55 pour vous dire
que vous avez vu dieu dans cet exercice
lévitation
oui j'ai l'impression
bonjour voila
vous habitez de quartier depuis quand
même temps au depuis toujours je suis
l'école où sacha la rue car pas la folie
voilà vous êtes au courant de
l'opération état civil 1991
et bien sachez que vous êtes à deux
millionièmes française qui est passé sur
la place du panthéon depuis le 1er
janvier
quel est votre rêve enfin moi j'aime mon
quartier
on va écouter vous allez y rester je
vous expliquer pourquoi
parce qu'il ya un prix c'est pas un
voyage au c'est pas de l'argent mais
nous allons admettre au panthéon grâce
au service de l'état civil et à toutes
les institutions françaises
nous allons admettre au panthéon de la
première française inconnue qui donc
comme le soldat inconnu va avoir la même
valeur symbolique évidemment est ce que
vous êtes surprise et tenez bon je suis
un peu étonné bien sûr est-ce que c'est
l'émotion qui parle
oui certainement vous n'êtes pas de la
famille du soldat inconnu qui est
enterré à l'appeler trio
un mec 65
ça va faire du à 70 je prends pas de vue
ses projets au total ont joué bien sympa
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça obligeait
tous visés c'est le plus tard possible
évidemment bernard subert c'est la
couleur des cheveux voulait bouge alors
ben j'étais acajou quand j'étais très
jeune j'étais
que doivent se dire on nous voyez
c'était très laid il cherche de rousseur
va bien très bon alors alors je vais
vous donner donc il ya une petite
question c'est juste par rapport à la
culture que vous avez deux de france
savait que donc sont enterrés au
panthéon les skis les français les plus
justes au nombre desquels nous comptons
une erreur alors qu'elle est le français
en terro poteo qui ne mérite pas de
n'être thierry la fronde à liège au bout
d'un nom nationale attendait parce que
notre en jésus-christ
klaus barbie
oui là ni l'autre c'est à dire ben qui
avait affronté qu'un acteur barbie c'est
connu oui c'était son vrai nom était en
boudin et d'ailleurs je lui ai expliqué
mme champoux d'elle voilà et regardez
jean boudin est enterré oui voilà cette
fois j'allais dire voilà il est en
théorie et vous vous serez je montre
caméra vous vous serez à la droite de
jean moulin
c'est la personnalité quand même qui
était la plus visitée au panthéon et
même vous dire quelque chose en toute
confidentialité
jean boudin est à ce point visité au
panthéon qu'il ya que le métro qui
laissa pas passer d'eux sourit jean
bouteille voilà tout
est ce que vous pouvez me dire qu'est ce
que vous ressentez par rapport à
l'honneur évidemment qu'on le fait
d'être enterré à la droite de jean bodin
s'est attirée la fonda les agents
c'est impressionnant
et ça donne à réfléchir
vous plaisir votre petit chien est ce
que vous souhaitez qu'il soit derrière
jean boudin devant dit de nous pour les
facilités regarder il peut pas être à
côté
ceux ci n'ont plus cours ballard a
compris d'accord très bien alors ce
qu'on va faire pour immortaliser cet
endroit pour immortaliser donc ce moment
on va vous demander de vous diriger vers
le panthéon aux grands hommes la patrie
reconnaissante
avec sociale donc vous avez vous diriger
vers le panthéon oui en tâtonnant bien
haute
1 et non laisser parler votre émotion
quand vous marchez vers le panthéon et
nous souhaitons un bon voyage avance
[Musique]
grand débat d'actualité aujourd'hui la
liberté de la presse écrite en france
est ce que vous êtes favorable la
liberté de la presse écrite en général
ou en particulier c'est bien ce que vous
refusez la censure sous toutes ses
formes
pas de censure
jamais dans aucun cas
pourquoi la liberté donc vous vous serez
prêts à manifester notre solidarité dont
cas où un confrère journaliste de la
presse écrite alors été censurés ou pas
est ici comment la manifesterez elle
vous et à quelle heure
ah ben ça je faisais pas commencé à
manifester mais je suis pour la liberté
de la presse et mais vous sentez
solidaire et c'est pour dénoncer donc la
censure que vous pensez être une
injustice ou le lady en filigrane
qu'elles sont un confrère de
journalistes de la presse écrite a été
injustement censuré il est là
aujourd'hui
comme vous le voyez il a décidé et
s'immoler par le feu
et ouais c'est monsieur donc ces
bayonnais volontairement pris et il a
décidé de s'immoler par le feu pour
merrill a été censuré parce qu'ils sont
journal n'a ces petits comme vous voyez
ce journal la sceptique et d'inspiration
c'est génial mais c'est jacques séguéla
c'est un philosophe publicitaires vous
avez dû lire ses livres
donc le 20e cette soirée médiatique ne
sera pas jacques séguéla ce journal donc
avec demander à ce monsieur de faire un
papier sur la liberté de la presse
écrite en france
voici le résultat mais je le monte au
téléspectateur d'antenne 2 voici ce
qu'il en reste c'est à dire victime
d'intention
il ya donc décidé de s'immoler par le
feu
est ce que vous pensez donc dû combattre
ce jeune homme et de ce qui s'est passé
de cette décision arbitraire et c'est
parce qu'il a écrit mais enfin je pense
que
du monde peut écrire oui y'a pas de sens
c'est bien chers téléspectateurs il est
12h vin madame violon de manifester sa
solidarité à l'égard du combattant ce
jeune homme de ce jeune confrère de la
presse écrite
bernard deringer j'ai donc demandé
madame manière la plus symbolique qui
soit évidemment de craquer une allumette
donc permettre à ce jeune homme
d'aller jusqu'au bout de son combat
évidemment et donc de s'immoler par le
feu
mercier genève a bien voulu réserver
l'exclusivité de
son action à antenne 2 et à nos chers
téléspectateurs
m
j'étais solidaire vous avez dit que vous
seriez prêts à vous battre pour wii non
mais moi je me patrick allaume surtout
c'est lui qui décide de le faire alors
et qui met serait lui m il va jusqu'au
bout de ce de sa décision pourquoi moi
pour trouver moi je vais le faire ce que
je me demande est ce que je peux faire
moi même
mais la juste
attendez attendez voile sur quelques
caméras sur scène
la première fois le fait ça ah oui
combien cela commençait à ce léger
ça quand même
oui
[Musique]
reste à la barre
ah oui est ce que ça peut exploser
ah ben alors mettez-vous peut-être en
arrière parce qu'effectivement vous avez
raison je restais la souplesse il ya des
risques
à bon entendeur fois que ça trop tard
mettez-vous ça alors est ce que vous
êtes favorable envers tes expressions
mais oui oui oui sous toutes ses formes
sous toutes ses formes
d'accord
l'unité française oui très bien bonjour
est ce que vous connaissez les émissions
de télé achat sur antenne 2 oui
vaguement je les ai vu une fois d'accord
alors je vous expliquer en quoi consiste
le téléachat d'aujourd'hui nous avons
décidé de descendre dans la rue pour
promotionner les porte d'honneur mais
les vrais pas les bagues qui connaissait
comme donneuse hubert et tous les
scandales qui a eu voilà tout l'effectif
ça ne nous intéresse pas vous en avez
pour bonheur non ci dessous vous êtes
j'y crois pas trop
s'il ya un objet quand même qui vous
intéresse je pense et je vais vous le
présentez vous savez je vais vous le
présentez venez le saut daniel vous
connaissez la connaissiez superstition
donc des beaux succès avec eux toucher
la bosse d'un bossu ça porte chance
est ce que vous saviez ça mais je n'aime
pas tellement genre de choses parce que
c'est basé sur la raillerie de se moquer
d'un étron voilà alors j'aime pas trop
en dessous voilà eh bien nous nous
sommes arrêtés mondiale à nous si non
seulement de la respectons nous avons
même décidé si vous voulez de nous mener
à de mener un conjointement avec ce
monsieur
une opération à but lucratif évidemment
pour éviter les railleries
c'est pourquoi j'ai vous précisez tarifs
nettement venir y moi vous savez que les
grands du monde des grands de ce monde
c'est à dire de gorbatchev vers esat des
grandes marches congrès de lemon
également sur son vélo ont touché des
boss vous savez je pense que je suis
l'actualité pas dans ce genre de détails
d'accord
eh bien ceux qui n'ont pas touché des
bosses comme par exemple monseigneur
glem comme également daniel gilbert qui
a rallié fait évidemment d'en toucher
une honte
malheureusement non pas celui de bonheur
bon alors vous l'avez dit la chance
alors le prix est touchée de bosses
aujourd'hui et à différents mais nous
faisons exceptionnellement une promotion
trois touchés de bosses donc pour 20
francs
voilà alors je vous présente donc le
téléachat d'aujourd'hui je venais venait
que moi et donc pour différents vous
allez droit de toucher cette bosse qui
vous apporte vous nous avez dit tout à
l'heure
là la chance voilà alors vous la touchez
s'est dit franck de toucher trois
semaines
alors allez-y voilà c'est dit feront
donc le téléachat d'aujourd'hui
tant mieux parce que sinon fermez les
yeux
le service après vente fonctionne 24
heures sur 24 donc sur minitel vous
tapez 36,15 la bosse c'est différent
bonjour la braguette de votre casquette
alors elle est ouverte ainsi de rien hop
hop hop hop
john baguette est ouverte baguette pas
de baguette fabregas
quel âge at il donc
c'est pas le comment de bouteilles voilà
donc on va faire un essai pour vérifier
que vos versions d un stade et on va se
bouge pas vous êtes prête il va vérifier
que vous n'êtes tiennent bien attention
vais trier est ouverte
ce spectacle amérique le carré blanc et
d'ailleurs il l'a le carré blanc est ce
qu'on peut faire de la publicité pour
votre établissement
ça vous en êtes pas d'accord alors tu
filmes dessous juste dessous faut faire
un sourire merci super votre braguette
braguette votre braguette ouverte votre
braguette dans la langue française et en
orthographe question de graff le mot
écrit tu reprends un thé ou de thé
intégré avec combien de sucre baguette
notre baguette
ce votre braguette ouverte au bond merci
à rien
[Musique]